je vous disais suggestions de livres et
de musique rebecca bonsoir bonsoir pas
très joli album oui en fait ce soir on
fait des suggestions cadeau pour votre
chef d'antenne les choix de la prise ce
soir on va commencer avec tracy chapman
que vous aimez beaucoup oui c'est une
auteure compositrice interprète ya
vraiment une carrière constante
peut-être un peu discrète parce que moi
il n'était plus vraiment sur mon radar
en fait savoir je suis très fier de
l'aligner mongrain non non non non non
c'est mon erreur parce que parce que
tout a commencé en 1988 avec ce premier
album écoulé à plus de 10 millions
d'exemplaires
cette chanson
l'espoir
15 sec 2
m
hollande
mais
gadio
la cote mais le deuil
m
donc moi je suis un genre de meilleur
culpa parce que pour moi l'expérience du
président s'étaient pas de me replonger
dans les grands succès de tracy chapman
c'était carrément presque de découvrir
l'oeuvre de cette atmosphère l'enjeu
numéro huit albums ça fait longtemps
qu'on leur foute à nouveau je pense que
ça fait déjà six sept huit ans mais
cette fille est poignante
elle est touchante et elle a une seule
plume qui lui permet de traverser les
années sans prendre une ride
donc c'est vraiment une fois une force
tranquille tracy chapman
elle milite elle proteste à travers le
prisme du phoque est une voie là où
c'était bien dit j'ai bien dit à brest
prend des notes mais voilà je suis j'en
prends mentalement et c'est noël c'est à
m
vous voulez vous que vous me fassiez une
suggestion de 10 de noël seul humain
maryse letarte maryse letarte bon qui
nous a fait un beau cadeau à peu près 6
7 ans avec un décor dans l'anarchie qui
est devenu parce qu'enfin des chansons
originales de noël et cet album patrice
maryse l'appartement voyais aujourd'hui
la version taïwanaise de cet album des
pas dans la neige qui a été en europe en
asie aux etats-unis donc voilà la maison
10 taïwanaise qui a décidé de reprendre
les paroles en mandarin à auron désolé
on avait demandé à maryse letarte une
adaptation française de la chanson vous
entendez en ce moment le boum boum boum
pour diffuser durant le souper de noël
pour les enfants à euro disney alors à
la vie avec la parade
la version française de bombo mulliez et
ça c'est son nouveau disque de neige
vous propose d'écouter peut-être la
chance ensuite allongés
eton
de dissiper
corps
il
hier
c'est au bout du nez
ce qu'on aime c'est que j'ai appris mon
cas ma liste d'attenté fait des études
en jazz en arrangements big bang alors
sur le disque ça joue vraiment côté
merveilleux de noël et il n'y a pas de
mention de jésus du père noël c'est
presque un accommodement raisonnable cet
album en fait on parle d'amour de sapins
divers de cadeaux s'est plaint
d'onomatopées il ya des cuivres des
cordes du glockenspiel mais aussi on
dirait que c'est moi que ça a été fait
avec des jouets pour enfants c'est
vraiment c'est très vrai en titre échoue
wolof et là on se laisse avec un cadeau
plus pour moi c'est une autre révélation
radio-canada musique c'est le braque que
j'aime beaucoup dont le deuxième album
portrait de famille figurent sur les
tops le palmarès des artistes de cette
année effet les bras vient de nous
offrir est assez disponible sur son site
web colorier avec braque un livre à
colorier en france et un espagnol pour
adultes donc on ne peut pas le
feuilleter en anglais mais c'est très
drôle très bien la drôle et je pense
qu'on aurait seul essai avec christelle
peut-être oui et avant je vous je vous
indique mais n'avait jamais su que
toutes ces suggestions de rebecca de
claudia livres musique ce raid se trouve
sur une page facebook téléjournal 18
heures c'est déjà là on vienne vérifier
alors si vous n'êtes pas pris le temps
d'écrire
voilà la solution on se quitte donc oui
mais on se retrouve en 2016 merci